Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Zombie Night Terror.
Now we're going to be continuing our rampage of destruction
and just judging by the toolbar down here,
there seems to be a lot of other things
that we can do.
There's like a claw type thing
A big ol' Hulky monstrosity
Explosions, speed, spit
Sonic BOOM
and what I can only assume
is a Hadouken
or a Kamehameha wave but either way.
There is a lot more depth to this game
and I can't wait to get to it
but first,
I gotta get through this game
and see if I can figure out how to do this.
But I believe if I'm gonna do this, I've got to go this way first.
Hey! NO!
There's a guy with a baton!
Go the other way!!!
Yea, that guy's awfully confused
Because the guy ran screaming about zombies
And then suddenly..
This guy grew a giant, pulsating ballsack.
Does that guy have a shotgun?
I'm pretty sure that guy has a shotgun,
so I'm gonna take him out.
Erm, I dunno my guys could probably..
Can- whoa, what the hell?
Dude!
Dude, calm down! It's okay!
How much- How much damage is-
..wow.
Oh my god, that got two!
That's okay, it didn't do that much.
Okay,
why're you trying to bash down that wall, dude?
Seems like..
Dude!
You okay?
You alright?
You seem to be undergoing some stress.
Whoaaaa.
Oh GOD!
Oh, too late. He didn't even get one hit off.
Ahhhhhh!
Welp, they're dead.
Welp, you're dead you should've moved.
Okay, sorry...
Damnination
WOO!
EXPLODE?!
Hell yes! I wanna explode!
Oh I know what to do
Ok, so I gotta wait until there's like, one...
Oh jeez, that's a big explosion radius...
OH, WHY ARE THEY ALL GROUPED UP?!?!
Oh, WHAT A LOAD OF BULLCRAP.
Hang on, I gotta speed through this.
*high pitched* Budda-bibbita-boop badder doodly!
Ok, so, what I am gonna do is make them go down, except for one of them... KA-BOOWSKY!
That's three of them, but, ya know, I'll take the risk.
Sorry buddy, you're uh.. you've just got your friends with ya.
HUUUAAGH *farting noise*
OH MY GOD, THAT WAS HORRIFYING. I gotta do that AGAIN?
Ah, SH*T DUDE. I gotta do that how many times?
Oh, jeezums.
Alright, hang on.
*High pitched* Hibba dip biddle boody, app!
That's the cops? Whaddya mean that's the cops- oh, geez...
Uh, oh, Oh, OH, OH. OH.
That's alotta gunfire for not like-
GAHD DAMNNIT YOU MADE ME MISS MY
What the hell is happening here??
Guys...
Guh- guys...
Guh....guys...
....guys...
.........guy....guys...
I mean as entertaining as that is,
You made me miss my opportunity here,
So IIIIIIIIII
oh gOD THATS NOT THE RIGHT WAAAY
alright imma try-
heh-HABUDUH
Okay, that was good enough, alright.
Alright get back over there,
NO DON'T DO THAT- eeuuug
okay
we'regonnagodownhere
oh jeez once theyre down there, there's really no-
-shakin this one.
Well okay this guys a straggler tho
So i'm gonna try and get him
heh heh heh heh heh heh
oH I DONT FEEL SO GOOOD
bllleech!!
Alright, we're good (x4)
Alright so uh
You know probably walking into the hailstorm of gunfire
...probably wouldn't be a good idea
But they don't seem 'ta be able to hit anything, so maybe it wouldn't be too baaad
But instead i'm gonna go-BLOHIDONTFEELSOGOOD
[blech]
Oh it just pushed him aside, it didn't even kill the guy, that's nice.
That's very nice.
I know, I know I have one of those.
I'm na- i'm just not gonna do it.
okeh.
Heeh! You stupid human pieces of crap!
heeh- wut?
Oh x3
Jesus.
That- oH WHY
WHY??
wuh- why did they suddenly turn into huu-ma- uh, zombies?
...that didn't make any sense at all..
...alrighty then.
What are you doing?
Oh leave that poor guy alone!
....I think you (unintelligible) miss..
Okay, bash down this door,
*whiny* bash dow- oh.
HAAAAAAAAH- boh
aw, god, its so vicious!
JESUS..
That's like, one of my worst things, in any movie or like,
horror- horror thing like that
I-If a character dies and they /explode/ like that
oh I cant STAND it, its AWFUL.
HWAAAAAAHHH
Oh geez- sorry dude! ...wow.
..wow..
ooff, I am sorry- you know what, just for
Just for shits and giggles you guys are gonna have a good time.
I mean, /not/ a good time- wwhoa that's not good.
Oop! Sorry, sorry lady. Wow I really-
-I really didn't do you a favor there lady did I.
..alright..
Dude is that your van?
We're gonna beat the shit out of your van dude!
Hey!
Hey 'cmon now.
...hey 'cmon.
Alright...
BYE EVERYBODY! :D
wuh-BYE!
okay....BLLEEEEEEEEH.
*chuckles* "No Parking Completed", is that-
I didn't even know what th- I didn't even know what the extra challenge was
I just DID it anyway....OOPS.
oh boy- oooo where are we now?
We're going into the basement.
I'll try to do this one a bit more quickly.
*high pitched* fribbadip-shap-burdu-dudu-du-du
*still squeaky* ♫her du DOODLE doodle doodle dooh wUUoh~♫
Boink.
Okay so it just PUSHES the other zombies away
It doesn't necessarily blow /them/ up, which is awfully nice.
dur dur dur du- oh I dont have enough DNA for this ♫
How do I get more DNA- ooh I gotta, I gotta
err, no not you, not you.
But then a little bit of YYYOUU- everywhere.
Burn you, okay, that's good.
Okay just gonna burn you too,
Good job away there
[weird mark nosies]
okay
"Huh, there it is again. You didn't hear th-" *laughs*
You didn't hear the giant explosions?
HUUH.
I wonder what they could have been~
"No explosion that could reach us here. We're perfectly safe"
...oohhh suuUUuure y'aaare.
i'm suuuure y'aaaaare.
Okay so how could...I get explosions to reach all the way up there..?
hwoh jeez- Okay so I got DNA for an Overlord
*squeaky propeller noises*
Ooo maybe I can make an Overlord explode and it would be an even bigger... piece of damage.
Is that.. *gasp* it WOULD BE. I am correct!
*screaming* HYYEAAAH- oh my GOD.
OHHH MAAAN.
*smug* You hear that one asshole-
AND THEN he just goes back to WORK??
oh jeez...well..
Frankly you deserve that one. (harsh)
ohhhhh jeez... oohh
~I love this game so much~ Why do I love this game?
What did I do?
"Find a way out of the underground passage"
"Subway Massacre: Kill every human"
Do I wanna do that?
Man, thats alotta huMANZ
Where are they gonna go- oh its a sprawling level.
wait is that zombies over there?
Wait where did you guys come from?
Well DO something 'ya dicks!
...alright fine then.
I'll make my way- wow that's a lot of zombohs- okay?
uuuuum we need an Overlord
and we need to burn you and you..
okay, try that, you go that way
Alright and then- uhoh! /UUUGH/
Alright, got that guy, I don't think we actually needed to do ALL of that, but y'know
I'm an overachiever. (sure Mark)
ahh we need to put an Overlord over here.
GUYSWATCHOUT
It's DAAANGEROUS.
..alright..
So what we need to NOT do
Oh we need to have another overlord up TOP
Because its too much- too much up there
Oh no wait, no this is good
okay BAM...okay.
Then that guys gonna bash open that one
Then hang on, lemme just... wait..
Guyswakeup- wait
/HUURG/
Okay that guys dead-
"What's the trouble, alien invasion?"
Oh that guys on the toiiilet, thats no good...
Okay so,
Uuh~
Alright, so now, this guy goes away x2
hey wut- weyh- watya ya think ya doin
we-where- where do you think ya goin, Bubba?
Alright, so
Now they're goin that way- AHH I musta messed something up there..
eeh maybe not
That would take alot of explosions..
But I DO like explosions...
/BUURH/- oh, jesus,
/mmMMMMBUURH/ ohh jeezums